this is pretty funny our friend Kyle
kolinsky over at secular talk covered an
aspect of the passing away of former Fox
News chairman Roger Ailes a few days ago
that we didn't cover and Kyle did a
story about Fox News hosts who were very
visibly emotional which is fine but they
also argued oddly that in some way Roger
Ailes saved the the country of the
United States which is a hard thing to
believe that Roger Ailes did here's Kyle
talking about it here's the clip let's
take a look the hosts on Fox and Friends
reacted to Roger Ailes death and I
wanted to cringe along with all of you
meetings that he would hold twice a year
here at Fox News about how he started in
the in the business he was actually a
production assistant at stations in
Cleveland at Philadelphia he eventually
worked his way up to run the Mike
Douglas show in three years he went from
PA to EP of the most successful daytime
talk show maybe ever he got the biggest
guest to arrive in Ohio and do his show
from Bob Hope Ron down Roger believes
and hard work he ran for political
campaigns many people out there would
say that he saved this country by
starting the Fox News Channel Roger gave
every single one of us on this couch an
opportunity he put food on our table and
you know he went out in such a sad way
but who doesn't have sense we all have
our sins we all have our cross to bear
and Roger I will love you forever you
gave me an opportunity and I will
forever ever ever be grateful I know I
would not have gotten this job if it
weren't for you now the hope that you
rest in peace Roger and I hope that you
are at peace I know that his impact on
the country is it is beyond a shadow of
a doubt you think that he saw Nixon in a
green room that's right really Michael
saw him as an underdog I says you got to
like television next II know he's
helping Richard Nixon get elected you
got to change your message and he
started talking to him he said you can't
hate televisions not going away it's not
a fad yeah I was so disgusting
he's touting me any work with Nixon who
done that on Nixon yeah that ended well
right she okay one of them said many
people would say he saved this country
what by starting Fox News Fox News okay
launch a ninety six they're probably the
biggest impact they had was Bill
O'Reilly every night going on air and
pounding away about how we need to do
the war in Iraq and remember by then he
was the number one show he was the
number one show for a long time so he
had people across the country watching
this guy there's no anything doing
propaganda for the administration
screaming about how we need to invade a
country that didn't attack us because of
made-up weapons of mass destruction and
a threat against us that was not real so
they you know you could partially credit
them for being part of the media frenzy
frenzy and pile on that got us into a
war where we blew seven trillion dollars
and killed 200,000 innocent civilians
and of course they were staunch
defenders of torture and extrajudicial
prisons and NSA spying remember that all
Sean Hannity in his all they hire idiots
and raging hypocrites Sean Hannity under
the Bush administration was a spy NSA
spying if you're not in favor of it
you're with the terrorists yeah this is
just very very strange to argue that
Roger Ailes was one of the most powerful
media people in the country for some
period of time that makes sense to me he
clearly was Fox News the highest-rated
cable network for a very very long time
that makes sense to me but he saved the
country save the country from what would
be my question and after this that this
happened and as we talked about I don't
go around wishing for people's death I
don't think it's okay to sort of delight
in the fact that someone died whatever
it was that Roger Ailes did while he was
alive he was someone's husband someone's
father someone's child although
presumably his parents had sent
passed away but my thought when I heard
of the passing of roger ailes was
actually all the people whose lives were
damaged by roger ailes and how do they
feel about this we know that it was what
a dozen or more women who alleged that
they were sexually harassed or assaulted
by roger ailes and just sort of surreal
to see someone who we know so much about
what he's accused of doing and then
seeing people on fox news in this sort
of delusional manner that were
accustomed to seeing on fox news saying
that this is a guy who saved the country
it's kind of what we would expect to see
on fox news that type of hyperbole and
this time it applies to one of their
former employees